so in each of these pictures we have a
different scenario we have someone
standing at the edge of a cliff on earth
and in this first scenario they are
launching a projectile up into the air
in this one they're just throwing it
straight out they're not throwing it up
or down but just straight out and here
they're throwing the projectile at an
angle downwards and so what we're gonna
do in this video is think about for each
of these initial velocity vectors what
would the acceleration versus time the
velocity versus time and the position
versus time grass look like in both the
Y and the X directions so I encourage
you to pause this video and think about
it on your own or even take out some
paper and try to solve it before I work
through it so let's first think about
acceleration in the vertical dimension
acceleration in the Y direction we're
assuming we're on earth and we're going
to ignore air resistance we can assume
we're in some type of a laboratory
vacuum and this person has maybe an
astronaut suit on even though they're
out on earth what would be the
acceleration in the vertical direction
well the acceleration due to gravity
will be downwards and it's going to be
constant we're going to assume constant
acceleration so the acceleration is
going to look like this and if the
magnitude of the acceleration due to
gravity is G we could call this negative
G to show that it is a downward
acceleration once the projectile is let
loose that's the way it's going to be
accelerated now what about in the X
direction well if we assume no air
resistance then there's not going to be
any acceleration or deceleration in the
X direction so it's just going to be
it's just going to stay right at zero
and it's not going to change and what
I've just drawn here is going to be true
for all three of these scenarios because
the direction and with which you throw
it that doesn't somehow affect the
acceleration due to gravity once the
ball is actually out of your hands so
now let's think about velocity so what
is going to be the velocity in the Y
direction for this first scenario well
we could take our initial velocity
vector that has this velocity and angle
and break it up into its Y and X
components so this
be its y-component you just take the top
part of this vector right over here the
head of it and go to the left and so
that would be the magnitude of its
y-component and then this would be the
magnitude of its X component so the Y
component it starts positive so it's
like that but remember our acceleration
is a constant negative so our velocity
is going to decrease at a constant rate
so our velocity in this first scenario
is going to look something is going to
look something like that now what about
the velocity in the X direction we see
that it starts positive so it's going to
start positive and if we're in a world
with no air resistance well then it's
just going to stay positive notice we
have zero acceleration so our velocity
is just going to stay positive
one of the things to really keep in mind
when we start doing two-dimensional
projectile motion like we're doing right
over here is once you break down your
vectors into x and y components you can
treat them completely independently that
something will decelerate in the Y
direction but it doesn't mean that it's
going to decelerate in the X direction
now what would the velocities look like
for this blue scenario well our velocity
in our Y direction we start off no
velocity in our Y direction so it's
going to be right over here but then we
are going to be accelerated downward so
our velocity is going to get more and
more and more and negative as time
passes and notice the slope on these two
lines are the same because the rate of
acceleration is the same even though you
had a different starting point now what
about the velocity in the X direction
here it looks like this X initial
velocity is a little bit more than this
one so maybe it's a little bit higher
but it stays constant once again now
let's look at this third scenario in
this third scenario what is our Y
velocity our initial y velocity well it
would look something like that and our
initial X velocity would look something
like that if we were to break things
down into their components so our Y
velocity is starting negative is
starting negative and it's just going to
get more and more negative once the
individual let's go
the ball because you have that constant
acceleration that negative acceleration
so it's gonna look something like that
and what about in the x-direction well
it looks like in the x-direction right
over here is very similar to that one so
it might look something like this I'll
draw it slightly higher just so you
could see it but once again the velocity
the x-direction stays the same because
in all three scenarios you have zero
acceleration in the X direction now last
but not least let's think about position
so they all start in the exact same
place at both the X and Y dimension but
as we see they all have different
initial velocities at least in the Y
dimension so let's start with the
salmon-colored one so the salmon-colored
one it starts off with a some type of
positive Y position maybe based on the
height of where the individual's hand is
and then what's going to happen well
it's going to have positive but
decreasing velocity up until this point
at this point its velocity is zero so
it's position is going to go up but at
ever decreasing rates until you get
right to that point right over there and
then we see the velocity starts becoming
more and more and more and more negative
so it would look something like
something like that now what would be
the x position of this first scenario
well if we make this position right over
here zero then we would have we would
start our x position would start over
here
and since we have a constant positive X
velocity we our exposition would just
increase at a constant rate it would do
something like that now what about this
blue scenario
well this blue scenario we are starting
in the exact same place as in our pink
scenario and then our initial y velocity
is zero and then it just gets more and
more and more and more negative so it
would look something it would look
something like this now what about the X
position well our x position we had a
slightly higher velocity at least the
way that I drew it over here so we our x
position would increase at a concert
rate and it would be a slightly higher
constant rate so it'd have a slightly
higher slope than we saw for the pink
one now the yellow scenario once again
we're starting in the exact same place
and here we're already starting with a
negative velocity it's only gonna get
more and more and more negative so it's
just gonna do something like this it's
gonna get more and more and more and
more negative it's a little bit hard to
see but it would do something like that
and if the in the x-direction our our
velocity is roughly the same as the blue
scenario that our X position over time
for the yellow one it's gonna look
pretty pretty similar so this is just a
way to visualize how things would behave
in terms of position velocity and
acceleration in the Y and X directions
and to appreciate whan how to draw and
visualize these graphs and conceptualize
them but also to appreciate that you can
treat once you break your initial
velocity vectors down you can treat the
different dimension the X and the y
dimensions independently